alors jean et josette le client idéal
pour une interview alerte aux roses bien
sûr en accouchant d'un meeting on ne
bouge pas pendant un meeting à la bouche
dans le génial bien voir les emails
lazio elle est née à bon chat est un
chat mort alors doc gynéco vous préférez
draguer ou vous faire draguer draghi
largué vous faire larguer me faire la
rue
embrassez vous faire embrasser ça je
fais vraiment c'est réservé à une élite
de filles moi ça me brise le coeur
noailhac à 8 900 filles qu'on croirait
vous préférez caresser ou faire caresser
car il sait aussi qu'elle est le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour at on appris
d'autres je pensais que vous préférez
défoncer au fait fini c'est fini pour ce
parti-là de l'interview est le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour henri un porche
sous un porche où importe le lieu où
vous ne pouvez pas faire l'amour dans
une branche
oui est-ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour
j'ai besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
enfin j'ai besoin
50 50 mais soixante et un petit quelque
chose 60 40 60 pour le 51 40 40 pour
l'amour d'accord préférez une femme qui
baisent bien mec est infidèle ou une
femme qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle vraie question n'était sujets du
bac
alors ils vont tomber au bac dans
certaines pays bas je vais prendre la
fidl la fidl qui baisent mal elle aimera
s'assurant non ilike à vous après
changer d'avis oui une gonzesse vous
préférez qu'elle vous quitte pour un mec
pour une fille pour une fille ensuite je
pourrai le faire
est ce que tu vas être caressé par
quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu par
quelqu'un qui vous aime
oui le sado maso mais pourquoi pas je
suis pour le sexe et enfin et tout ces
diverses vous préférez une fille qui
couche avec un autre en pensant à vous
ou qui couche avec vous en pensant à un
autre je préfère une fille qui me
demandent de l'appeler [ __ ] put frère
ali plutôt que pense à un autre enfin
dans la vie j'appelle pas de tous les
jours j'appelle pas les filles puis tu
es seul tu mets oli webb le demande
souvent ces professionnels moi c'est un
assassin gynécologique
tu crois que tous les gynécos isabelle
leur passion comme ça
n'ont pas été bien rationnelle des
déchets non seulement c'est lui qui l'a
fait vous préférez pouvoir faire tout ce
que vous voulez avec une fille moche ou
juste embrassés sur la bouche une fille
sublime
moi je préfère la moche est ce que pour
vous embrasser s'est trompé ouais c'est
grave si votre mug embrasser un autre
mac vous considérer qu'elle vous trompe
avec le recul ouais ça peut faire mal
doc gynéco est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper si elle l'a bien fait enfin
comme comme je l'avais me concerne et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu